Golden hot bods, coming our way.
SPF1 hottie.
Heeey!
Hey should we head to the pool?
Yeah.
Cool.
Oh, hey uhm sorry you forgot your cellphone.
Oh, thank you.
Well well well, it looks like someone has a little crushy crush.
Phil, what's our smell status?
Uh, she put on some degree deodorant this morning after a shower.
Is it holding?
Still 85% effective, we're good.
Excellent.
You're going to let him get away?
Uhm.
Give me a line, Phil.  Quick!
Uh.
Hey fuck you!
Uh, I'm sorry?
For...looking so hot and...not asking me out.
Oh, it was a joke.
Yeah.
Ok.
You got lucky, Phil.
Should we just text him?  Say it was nice to meet him?
What did you say?
I just thought we could text him first.
Are you trying to destroy her, Mitch?
You know sometimes I like it when a girl texts first.
It's nice.
Ah!
We don't ever text first.
*text message sound*
Is that what I think it is?
Incoming text.
Read it, Mitch!
I hope you're getting this and didn't leave your phone somewhere, Megan.
Hahaha, how about a drink?
Yes!
What should we wear?
Nothing.
Risky but I like it.
No, nothing because we're not going.
This is a late night booty call text.
Ah, first date should always be lunch or dinner.
Right.
Respond and say that we already have plans.
Copy that.
New text.
Read it.
It says: Of course.  Sorry hope I didn't come off too forward.  Just really excited to see you again.
How about dinner tomorrow night?
All right!
Did you already respond to that, Phil?
Yeah, I just said:  Sounds good.  Added a little winky face, if that's okay.
No, it's not okay.
That winky face could compromise our entire operation.
Everything that we have worked for.  Confirm next time, Phil.
Before you execute an action.
Y-yes, captain.
It's probably fine.
See boys, all we need is a little patience.
I don't want to be too optimistic but I think this could be the one.
*Text message sound*
Oh shit.
Dick pic?
Yeah.
Damn.
Well, there's always tomorrow.  Huh, Captain?
Yes.
Tomorrow's a new day.
It's a shame we had to see that...dick pic.
And not in real life.
I'd like to say thank you to Audible for sponsoring today's episode
and someone asked me to do a chipmunk voice
so here it goes:
Thanks so much to Audible for sponsoring today's episode.
They have over 180,000 titles to choose from.
Right now I'm listening to "Death and The City of Light" because serial killers.
You can get that or another free audiobook of your choice
over at Audible.com/Anna.  That's Audible.com/Anna
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.